From the beginning of time, games have brought us together, players and spectators...
...by the handful, the hundreds and the thousands.
We built stadiums, places to gather around every kind of spectacle;...
...glory, tragedy, pageantry, community, rivalry and wonder...
...until every city, town and village had a place where anyone could play.
Thousands of years in, our games have changed,...
...but our need to come together remains.
This new era of gaming needs a new place to gather,...
...one place where anything you dream can be built,...
...playgrounds for every imagination;...
...one place where you and everyone you know and everyone they know will all play together...
...from any screen at any time,...
...one place for all the ways we play.
This is Stadia.
Gather round.